I told you yesterday how yet again the
Donald Trump campaign has changed
campaign managers first it was Corey
Lewandowski then he was fired Paul
Manafort comes in total disaster polls
fall off a cliff so mana fort is now the
chairman even though he's no longer in
charge and the co managers of campaign
are and I'm not kidding here
the Breitbart news CEO I mean I can't
even say that with a straight face and a
strategist named Kellyanne Conway so on
to CNN comes Trump organic organization
Michael Cohen special counsel to Donald
Trump apparently a lawyer and he goes on
CNN to say no this is not a shake-up
nothing is wrong this is an expansion of
the campaign by just bringing in winners
bringing in good people which led CNN's
Brianna Keilar to say why wouldn't there
be a shake-up you guys are losing and
then I don't know if Michael Cohen
genuinely doesn't realize that Trump is
losing in 22 over the last 22 polls or
he was pretending not to but it led to
one of the most awkward moments of the
Trump campaign that I can remember let's
take a look at the video strap
yourselves in
I recommend get the kids out of the room
take a look you say it's not a shake up
but you guys are down and it makes sense
that there would most of them all of
them
yikes he says who polls I just told you
I answered your question okay which
polls all of them okay and your question
is okay so my question is I don't think
it is really surprising when facing a
challenge and trying to make a
turnaround that there would be some
let's it let's at least say some
adjustments okay so I guess what my real
question is here that I did not get to
get to is what is the point of this if
you're calling it an expansion of of
winners as you put it working on the
campaign what is it about what to what
to what end well I think bringing on
somebody like Kellyanne Conway was a
great move and it was something
personally I would have liked to have
seen happen early
but the campaign wasn't ready for it now
they are I think she's a brilliant
individual I think that you know um she
understands the data that's coming in
look Hillary Clinton's got 14 I think or
13 different pollsters that are working
on creating her message so when she
talks about usage of a teleprompter by
Donald Trump okay let's go clue without
her script writers and so prompter
Michael Cohen the same guy who
previously said he works for the Trump
Organization not the campaign now says
oh I've been wanting someone like
Kellyanne Conway to get involved earlier
this is a lie people lost it they were
like oh look at biased CNN look at what
Brianna Keilar said yes she just
reported fact I'll show you a image here
of the last 22 polls and it's a lot of
blue there Louis you will see that every
single one of the last 22 polls has
Hillary Clinton ahead I don't get the
sense that Michael Cohen is necessarily
running on all cylinders during this
interview if you know what I mean well
if it seems like he really wasn't
working for the Trump campaign because
he has seems to have no clue what's
happening politically within the Trump
campaign or or even or he's lying across
the country or he's lying and I guess
you have to make the campaign seem
strong and that's why you're not calling
this a changeup but it is yeah if you
want to make the campaign seem strong
don't put the guy up there who doesn't
seem like he's playing with a full deck
to talk about how great things are